my apologies hello everyone
and welcome to today's webinar
validating a fluorescent cell sorter for
infectious disease and immunology
applications
i am serena demers of labruz and i'll be
your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by labruz and brought to you
by multne biotech to learn more visit
multnebiotech.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you're having trouble
seeing or hearing the presentation
i'd like to now welcome our speakers
matt riddle flow cytometry specialist at
milton e biotech and marissa falberg
assistant director for flow cytometry
core at tulane national primate research
center
welcome you may now begin your
presentation
hello everyone i'm very excited that you
are all able to join us today we have a
fantastic speaker from tulane
university's national primate research
center who is going to share a
revolutionary way to work with
infectious materials
my name is matt riddle and i am mill
tennis flow cytometry specialist based
out of houston texas
before i introduce our speaker i'm going
to give a brief introduction into the
platform that she is going to be
discussing
the max quant title sales
i will describe the way that the sorting
has been done in the past
the problems that occur and what makes a
title unique from a bio safety
perspective to solve these problems
after my overview you will hear about
how this instrument is revolutionizing
cell sorting in the bsl3 environment
without further ado i'd like to
introduce the max quant title
it is a closed and self-contained
benchtop cell sorter
it is quite compact and it does not
require any fluidics which eliminates
sheath fluid or waste containers that
need to be stored underneath
the large external monitor makes it easy
to analyze data
and implement a gating strategy
a disposable sort cartridge holds the
sample and is housed in a closed and
temperature controlled chamber where the
sample can be kept at a constant
temperature from 4 to 25 degrees celsius
tito has three lasers one violet 405
nanometer one blue 488 nanometer and one
red 635 nanometer
there are eight fluorescent channels two
off the violet four off the blue and two
off the red
plus a backscatter off of all three
lasers inside scatter off the blue laser
you can find more information of the
title specs on the miltenny biotech
website
the title is capable of sorting many
complex phenotypes including
but not limited to t cells
nk cells
t-regs
b cells
microglia
yeast bacteria
ipsc cells and nuclei
and yes you did here right laboratories
are currently sorting yeast bacteria and
nuclei with the max quantity
as most of you may know sorting is
traditionally done in what we call a
droplet-based method as you see here
during this droplet method cells can be
subjected to high pressures and shear
forces
the cells are centered in a flow using
sheath fluid
they then enter the flow cell where they
are interrogated by the lasers
and proportioned into droplets
they are then subjected to a charge to
direct them into the appropriate
collection tubes below
during this process the high pressure
and open nature of the drop of base
sorter can create aerosols which can be
harmful to the user by putting
potentially dangerous substances in the
air
today you will learn about how the flow
cytometry core
at the tulane national primate research
center tested the maxquant title for use
in their bsl3 facility
but first you need to understand how
this flow sorter is different from a
droplet sorter and how miltoni
revolutionized the sorting process with
a result that significantly lowers the
risk to the users
at the heart of this solution is the max
quant
title cartridge it has three chambers
the input chamber
the positive chamber in the middle
and the negative chamber
all chambers can be accessed from above
through lure lock ports
different from the conventional droplet
sorters the mass quantity has no fluidic
paths inside the instrument
in other words the cells do not run
through the instrument itself
instead prior to the sort
cells are loaded into the cartridge and
remain in the cartridge throughout the
entire sort
your sample remains in an aseptic
environment until it is removed after
the sword is complete
to maintain the sterile environment of
the disposable cartridge each of the
three chamber
access points are covered with a lure
lock cap
and all ventilation ports are covered
with a 0.1 micron
hydrophobic air filter
this is especially important when
sorting in hazardous samples
to maintain an aseptic environment and
increase the user safety the cartridge
can be loaded and unloaded under a hood
here you can see the different chambers
of them along with the microchip which
contains the sorting valve
you'll see the input on the left the
positive in the middle and the negative
on the right
compared to the droplet style sorting
this sorting valve is how the title
isolates your cell of interest
with a low pressure flow your sample
will move from the input chamber
through the microchip where is
interrogated by the lasers
after these lasers is where the valve
sits
like a door the valve opens and closes
to control the direction in which the
sample flows
both the negative and positive
populations are kept in the cartridge
until removed by the user under a
sterile hood
at this point the sample can be taken
for further analysis
also the negative population can be
collected and sorted again
this process is best shown through an
animated video
first you will see where the light air
pressure enters the cartridge to create
the flow for your sample
this is where it will pass through at
the first 0.1
micron filter
this starts the mixing propeller to keep
your sample suspended
once you start your sort the cells move
from the input chamber
through to the microchip to either the
positive or the negative chamber
you can see here how they pass through
the lasers and the valve opens and
closes to control the flow of the green
target cells to the positive chamber
and the other cells into the negative
chamber
now that you've seen the instrument and
how it works i'm excited to introduce
our featured speaker dr marissa falber
she's assistant director of the flow
cytometry core at the tulane national
primate research center as an early
adopter of the title technology dr
fauberg is one of the most experienced
title users in the united states
she will discuss some of the testing
that was done in order to demonstrate
the safety of the instrument while
sorting hazardous materials
so at this point alternative
thank you for the introduction matt and
thank you to everyone for joining this
webinar
today i will be talking about
our journey
and experiences validating the title
for
bsl3 sorting
my name is marissa i am the assistant
director of the flow cytometry corps at
the tulane primate research center which
is located in covington louisiana it's
about an hour north of new orleans
we primarily focus on improving human
health outcomes from infectious diseases
the flow core is housed within the
division of immunology and we have both
analyzers and sorting services we
support
our internal investigators as well as
external collaborators and nih contracts
and we're always welcome to work with
anyone so if you're interested in
what we do and what we show you today
then
feel free to reach out
so
we have a lot of demand for sorting at
the primate center
both vsl2 and bsl3 pathogens as well as
select agents
which includes
tuberculosis
stars cov2 coccyxiala brunetti which
causes q fever
rickettsia parkouri anthrax rice and siv
siv is the simian or monkey homolog of
hiv
and
a lot of times
if
someone wants to store a pathogen that's
typically considered bsl2
we will often sort it
and consider it bsl3
uh when it comes to sorting
that's because
when pathogens are aerosolized they can
be more dangerous when you inhale them
as a mode of transmission
in comparison to a more natural route
like ingestion or
direct contact
for that reason
because aerosols are more dangerous when
they're inhaled
and because cell sorting creates
aerosols
conventional self-sorting is classified
as a high risk laboratory procedure
aerosols during sorting are most often
created during
an event like a nozzle being clogged or
obstructed
and
even
without a nozzle being clogged when high
pressures are used like 70 psi
to sort and 70 psi is a pretty standard
pressure to use in combination with a 70
micron nozzle
70 micro nozzles have a very steady
stream in general um so it's it's a
popular nozzle size but it does come
with a high pressure
component to it and so
there is always the risk of generating
aerosols
in conventional self-sorting
so i wanted to show a video
about
the most hazardous aerosol production
when a nozzle clogs
and this is a look inside of a
conventional
cell sorter this is from a bd facts aria
fusion
and at the top is the flow cell
and their nozzle
is right here it's a little white piece
and the stream flows through the nozzle
between the deflection plates here and
here
and down into the center piece here
and then from there if all is going well
the stream will be deflected
in one to four directions sorting your
desired cell types
however when this nozzle clogs
and that can be due to
various reasons um sticky
cells like cancer cell lines or dead
cells or
a sample that has a lot of junk or say
mucus in it
if a nozzle becomes clogged
and the stream deviates to the side here
and doesn't go right through the middle
it hits the side
it will create this cloud or plume of
aerosols
that gets everywhere
and this is um this is a home video so
it's not the best but
you can clearly see
a ton of aerosols being created here
and droplets of all sizes going in you
know a million directions
and on top of that when this happens
if you don't catch it right away and
turn the stream off
sample can also go into the wrong
collection tube and that contain can
contaminate your sample
and that is a real problem with
conventional sauce orders because
anything that's not sorted
is pushed into the waste that sample is
gone and
if you want to restore a sample because
it's been contaminated
then you would have to spend everything
down
and resuspend and sort again and now
you're also pushing your sample through
the disorder for a second time so
sequential sort
it's not the best for the cells
so it's a huge bio safety issue to have
a situation like this
and it can result in sample loss
to mitigate
the risk the biohazard risk of a clog
and
the aerosol formation
there are several safety mechanisms that
are in place and recommended
by the industry so one is to close this
door there's a physical barrier there
the second is to close that whole area
the third is to have your sorter inside
a laminar flow biosafety cabinet and the
fourth is to use an aerosol management
system which evacuates aerosols from
this area
and in combination this system does work
to vacate aerosols and keep the operator
safe
the problem with the system is that it
is
cumbersome
and it is time consuming
and it requires
ideally
that you test the aerosols on the same
day as a sort
so sort days already are generally
pretty long
and you have to set up the instrument
and that's for regular cell sorting if
you add the aerosol management component
because you're sorting something that
could be dangerous upon inhalation
it's going to add a substantial amount
of time
and difficulty
so an ideal system
that's better than the current
conventional system is one
in which no aerosols are created
if that is not possible then the second
best would be a system in which some
aerosols may be created but they cannot
escape
and you don't lose sample if the system
fails
so we turn to the title
as a potential candidate self-sorter for
our bsl3
to see if this instrument which is a
microfluidic cell disorder and has a
completely different way
of sorting compared to conventional cell
sorters
to see if it could solve these problems
and bring us closer to the ideal
solution or system that we want which is
essentially to create few or no aerosols
and not allow them to escape
the way that the title works which is
unique from a conventional cell sorter
is all of the sorting happens within
a cartridge that's made of a hard
plastic
instead of
going through tubes
and a flow cell and nozzle
everything happens inside this cartridge
so the instrument itself has no fluidics
inside of it the instrument has optics
and electronics but all of the sorting
and fluidics happens within the
cartridge
specifically in the chip the microchip
that is attached to the bottom of the
cartridge
and air comes in
through the input chamber this is the
input chamber
where you load your sample
and the air pushes cells through the
input chamber
pushes your sorted cells into this
middle chamber or the positive
collection chamber and the cells that
you're not interested in
into the negative collection chamber
there is a 100 nanometer hydrophobic
multi-layered filter
above each of these chambers which is
required for the airflow
within the input chamber there is a
mixing propeller that mixes at 800 rpms
it is adjustable
the reason for it is to keep the cells
in suspension
and then there's a 3d filter it's called
a 3d filter that the cells have to pass
through before they enter the microchip
and within the chip there is a magnet
well the magnet is in the instrument
within the chip there's a valve
that pushes the cells an incredibly fast
rate
into the positive collection chamber or
the negative collection chamber the way
that it's designed there are several
strengths
uh as pertaining to biosafety for
the title in comparison to conventional
cell sorters
so one is that the operation for a
regular cartridge because they just
recently came out with a high speed
cartridge the regular cartridge operates
at about three psi
i think it's actually a little bit less
on ours
and um 17 psi for the high speed
cartridge
in comparison i mentioned this earlier a
conventional cell sorter with a 70
micron nozzle
will operate at 70 psi
and if you use a bigger nozzle 100 micro
nozzle that's usually will sit between
20 and 23 psi which is lower
um in spite of that even the high speed
title cartridge is lower than that
so with the lower pressure fewer
aerosols are formed
you know status quo just
as it as it is
and then on top of that the system is
closed
besides the filters the three filters
located at the top which again are 100
nanometer pores
multi-layer
and they are hydrophobic
and there's no nozzle to clog that's the
big one
the clogging of the nozzle and that huge
cloud of aerosols
is the primary
cause of aerosol formation and
conventional disorder without a nozzle
that whole cloud of aerosols that you
saw goes away
there is a filter as i mentioned that
can be clogged and that could
potentially create a pressure issue an
increase of pressure into the input
chamber
if it's clogged and if the system is
trying to push cells through
in that case
you know you could have a higher
pressure situation which could create
some issues at the interface between the
air and the liquid
um but if the 3d filter is clogged the
other nice thing is that nothing goes to
waste
there
you know the sample that you don't sort
doesn't go into the waste it just goes
into this other chamber
so you never have to worry about sample
loss on the titan that's one of my
favorite things about it
if you were to
have to sort again for some reason
it's true that you would have to put the
sample through one more time
um just like you would a regular sorter
after you spin it down
but there's a big difference between
putting a sample through twice at 3 psi
or 17 psi
compared to
70 psi
some limitations of the system are
the mixing propeller
it does mix at 800 rpm to keep the cells
in suspension and that could cause some
splashing or aerosol formation
potentially
as i mentioned a partial or complete
clog of the filter here could increase
pressure on the system in order to try
to drive and push the cells through
and then the three openings on the top
of the chamber
are the only parts of the cartridge
which are exposed to the environment
and or to the air and that's where
aerosols could potentially escape
if they are less than 100
nanometers in diameter
and they would still have to pass
through
multiple layers and the filters being
hydrophobic
um you know would repel some droplets
but it is still possible
because they are open to the environment
just
um again
so we wanted to find out
if what we thought
was true about the title you know that
it wasn't
probably creating aerosols or if it was
they they were unlikely to escape
because of the design
and so we set about determining whether
aerosols were generated inside the
cartridge so within each of the three
chambers
in addition we wanted to
investigate whether aerosols were formed
outside of the three chambers and above
those filters
and finally we wanted to see whether any
aerosols that were
potentially generated outside of the
cartridge
were they escaping the instrument
above where the sort chamber door is
closed because typically you sort like
this with this drawer being closed
everything is happening inside here
but there is a little space here where
the door closes it's pretty snug but we
just wanted to see if aerosols could
escape through there
or alternatively if they could escape
through the bottom of the instrument
here because there is a vent system
where air that's
inside the instrument
gets pushed out
in this direction left to right
and so we wanted to test this error here
to see if aerosols could be in there
the industry standard for aerosol
testing
for conventional cell disorder
which has really been
defined
and optimized by steve perfetto at the
nih is to
create a worst case scenario artificial
clog
in the sorter nozzle as i showed you in
the video and the way you do that
artificially without actually clogging
the nozzle is you just move the sort
block
over to the left a little bit so that
the stream is hitting the side
of where it's supposed to be and
creates that big cloud
and then you run fluorescent beads
through the disorder at a very high
event right about 40 to 50 000 events
per second
the beads
that are typically used are one micron
in size
and that's because
when you analyze
a large number of aerosols
that are created from like what i showed
you in the video
the concentration
of beads at one micron in size
tends to be higher than beads below that
or
higher than that
so it's thought that using bees are one
micron
are a good representation
of whether you have aerosols of any size
if you don't see the one micron if you
can't detect the aerosols that are one
micron
then it's less likely that you'll detect
aerosols smaller or bigger than that if
that makes sense
and then we use cyclix d cassettes which
are these guys to sample the air at
various locations around the system
and these are very interesting these are
typically used for environmental
sampling
and so it's perfect for
this
what you do is you attach the cassette
to one end of
a tube and then the tube
is attached to this vacuum pump
which pulls in air at 20 liters per
minute so there's air being suctioned
through this vacuum at 20 liters per
minute
and you can sample various areas around
the instrument
to
see if you can identify aerosols so once
the air gets pulled into this cartridge
inside i'm sorry into the cassette
inside the cassette
there is an adhesive that's also
a mounting media
and the air gets pulled into the middle
and sticks to that mounting media
um that's on a cover slip
the cover slip sits like right in here
and then you can just take the cover
slip out and attach it to a slide and
look for the beads under a microscope
and if you see beads then that
is indicative that aerosols formed and
you were able to recover it from the air
by pulling it in through that vacuum
so that is the industry standard for
aerosol testing for conventional cell
disorder
we wanted to reproduce
that industry standard for the title as
closely as we could given that these are
very different systems
so we created or we we tried to design
this experiment where we would create a
worst case scenario clog
in the input chamber clogging of that
filter i mentioned earlier
we don't have a nozzle here
so where is the you know an effects aria
or fusion we would clog the nozzle here
we're clogging the filter in the input
chamber
secondly we would run fluorescent beads
just like they do in a conventional
sorter
except we ran beads that were 50
nanometers 100 nanometers and one micron
in size
instead of only one micron and that is
because
the the filters as i mentioned at the
top
of the cartridge here
these are 100 nanometers
so
just in although for conventional cell
sorter the one micron bead is a great
indicator of whether you're creating
aerosols smaller or larger than that in
this case the 100 nanometer filter is
preventing
beads that are one micron most likely
from escaping
but it doesn't mean that
aerosols aren't of smaller than 100
nanometers or 100 nanometers are not
escaping
so we couldn't just rely
on the one micron beats when testing
aerosols on the titan
so we
also found a way to move the beads
through at a very high event rate on the
title and then we use those cassettes to
cyclic stick assets to sample air
at the different locations around the
system and analyze those samples under a
microscope
initially we had to
do several optimizations
to get the testing in place first we had
to determine if we could even detect
these tiny bees under a microscope
because 15 nanometers
is incredibly small
and then we had to develop a method to
artificially clog the system because it
wasn't as easy as just moving a slot
block over and creating the cloud we had
to actually clog that 3d filter
and then we needed to determine the
sample volume required to maximize spray
potentially from that mixing propeller
so this is just showing that we were
able to identify the beads at 50
nanometers 100 nanometers and 1000
nanometers these are different
magnifications
and the 50 nanometer beads i'm just
pointing this out
they sometimes look a little bigger than
the 100 nanometer beads that's not an
air that is
uh aggregation so
although there were a lot of beads that
were by themselves so the
beads were still good to use for this
test
they were stickier
the 59 and we mean the beads were
stickier than the other sizes
but we could see them all
the clogging efforts is where things got
a little bit tricky
the system was very very difficult to
clog
which
is great for a sorter
but it is
challenging when you're trying to do it
on purpose for
aerosol tests
so we tested 10 micron beads which is
what you see here we tested trying to
clog the system with undiluted whole
blood
with whole blood mixed from several
animals in order to activate the cells
and try to get them to be stickier
both same day and overnight mixing
we tested homogenized brain samples with
and without
the junk that you get from
digesting the brain
from monkey in this case we tested cell
lines we tested thymocytes and
splenocytes that had
a lot of dead cells in them
we got desperate and so we tested
elmer's glue
at increasing concentrations and we even
tested agar
and tried to dry some agar on top of the
filter
at increasing concentrations
we were able
to clog
the system
basically we had two outcomes so we were
either we either completely clogged the
system in which case the pressure
actually dropped every time consistently
from 120 hpa
to 50 hpa which is about 0.73 psi
instead of the pressure
being greatly increased it just dropped
time after time
the other alternative
was
we were sometimes able to get the
pressure to go from 120 250 hpa at the
maximum
but that's a difference of going from
like two and a half psi to
i think like three or four
or five maybe psi
um
which is really nothing we could never
get the system to
get to a really high pressure
and here you can see
this is our data from the b testing
where the more the filter was clogged
the lower the pressure was and it was
linear
it was very clear
so
after all of these efforts to try to
clog it
which by the way the lack of being able
to clog it and the lack of being able to
get to a high psi
was really encouraging by itself as far
as putting us order on the bsl3 is
concerned
um but we still really wanted to try to
do this test
so
we decided to
artificially
you know
increase the pressure of the system
without there being a clock and you can
do that manually so we adjusted the
pressure to the maximum that the
instrument would allow before it
automatically turns off
which is approximately 14.14 psi and
that
converts to
um i think it's 975 hpa either 950 or
975. above that and the instrument will
just turn itself off so that's another
built-in safety feature of the title
so once we made that decision we moved
on to
figuring out if there was a volume
of sample
that hit the mixing propeller so that or
the agitator
so that the spray or splashing
caused by the mixing was
at its highest
and it was interesting
because
instead of finding a lot of spraying or
splashing
you can see here we use this red dye and
running buffer to try to find
spraying
that there there was none
there really wasn't
and the reason for that
is you can't see from this angle but if
you look down from the top
the way that the mixing propeller is
designed which is a great design
i've really come to appreciate it since
this test is it pulls a liquid inward it
creates basically a funnel in inward
it doesn't push the liquid out
so
it really has almost
i mean basically not basically there was
no spray that we could find
at about a sample volume of 450 and 850
microliters we did detect what we're
calling micro bubbles which were just
these really tiny bubbles
um in the solution and they would kind
of flow and then they would be pulled in
um
this is not
it was not really a concern but it was
the most that we could like perturb the
sample
so we decided to run at least one ml of
sample through the system and run it all
the way down to the bottom
so we could test sample at its maximum
you know disturbance
okay
so to sample the interior of the
cartridge this took a little bit of
creativity
we ended up
creating a system where we glued a
pipette tip
a very skinny pipette tip
to the lure lock
to the lure lock
and then we dipped the pipette tip into
a mounting medium that we make here at
chilean
and the mounting media doesn't drip it's
it's not so viscous
like it's good enough that we can dip
the pipette tip into it as far as
viscosity goes but it's viscous enough
that it also didn't drip into the sample
so it was
interesting to try to find
the right
material for this and also had to be
clear so it could be
put on a slide
so basically once we had this pipette
step that was dipped into the mounting
media we attached it
into all three chambers not just this
chamber
we attached it and then
we ran the sample
through the instrument and any aerosols
that were created would hopefully stick
to that mounting media
we also tested that the aerosols did
stick to mounting media with a spray
bottle and they did and then we could
pull out the pipette tip
and
rub them rub the tip over a slide
and then look at that slide in the
microscope
so this was the system for testing the
inside all three chambers of the
cartridges
to test the exterior of the cartridge
this is
more
along the lines of what you do for
conventional cell sorting so we use the
cyclix d cassettes
and we ran the samples for 10 minutes
like they do um
also for conventional sorting and we
tested two locations above the cartridge
so this one location
here above two of those filters and then
a second location above the third filter
here
so there were three interior
samples that we took
two exterior samples that we took
and then we also
um
did another sampling outside
of the closed sword chamber door
and this vent here that i mentioned
earlier
the results were
encouraging if not exciting
i mean
exciting in some senses and boring and
others but
we detected no aerosols of any size we
tested all three sizes with this method
the 50 nanometers 100 nanometers and one
micron beads
we didn't detect them at any size
from inside the positive or the negative
chambers
we weren't able to in the end so far we
haven't been able to make a
determination for the input chamber and
i'll explain why in the next slide but
we didn't detect any of the positive and
negative chambers
so that's like the pipet test the
pipette tip
we were also unable to detect beads of
any size outside of the cartridge
and we were not able to detect them
outside of the instruments
so
that was very encouraging we have
some work left to do
one is to determine the lower limit of
detection
um
we know that after looking at the slides
for hours so we were not able to see any
beads
um but we're working on
ensuring that we're looking at the right
plane
the right focal plane in the microscope
so that we're definitely not missing any
of those 50 nanometer beads because
they're hard to see
so
we're very confident that if aerosols
are generated it's very few
because we couldn't detect any
but we still need to go back and
create that threshold that lower limit
in addition
we
have to
optimize our
bead loading system
because when we loaded the beads we
accidentally touched the sides
unknowingly of the lure lock and so when
we took the pipette tips out they
brushed against the sides and
contaminated the sample
so we're working on a funnel system
to add the beads without touching the
sides and then we'll be able to get
those results
we need to repeat this for multiple lots
and also test the high speed cartridges
this should be really interesting
because they do operate at a higher
pressure than the regular cartridges
if we do
um detect beads say in the input chamber
aerosols in the input chamber
or after we do more replicates we detect
beads
in one of them
our plan is to think about adding a
layer of mineral oil
to the top
let's see
of the cartridge and go way back like
here
such that or even the top of the
the sorter chamber wherever we need it
if we need it would be to add a layer of
mineral oil
to prevent aerosols from escaping
through the top which i think
is a really interesting idea
and that would
also create a safer sorting scenario if
we had to
so i just wanted to give a big thank you
to megan varnado and katelyn didier
they are
specialists in
my
full core and our flowcore at tulene
they did a lot of this work
we have
had as i mentioned in the first slide
it's been a journey
trying to we thought in the beginning
that this would be very very easy and
it wasn't it was like i said like
impossible to clog
impossible to get the pressure high
um
lots of difficulties making this thing
break it does not break easily
and they have been very patient and
we've tried so many things to get to
this place so big thank you to both of
them for their persistence
and then from bill tenney daryl megan
ellie elaine matt duet crystal
extremely helpful extremely
knowledgeable
and i'm sure my conversations with them
will be continuing as we continue
testing
and my boss midi core from tulane and
cecily from the confocal core who made
the proprietary mounting media that we
were able to use in pipette sips because
all of the commercial ones that we
tested
did not work they all basically dripped
into the sample
and then just here this is not a very
good picture but this is our new title
in the bsl3
and we're not allowed to have cameras in
there our cell phones in there so it's
it's a picture taken from outside the
bsl3 actually but
we are very excited to start working on
it in this space
so thank you for your time and i'll be
happy to take any questions
thank you matt and marissa for your
informative presentations we will now
start the live q a portion of the
webinar
if you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now just click on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen we'll answer as many of your
questions as we have time for
let's get started our first question is
i work at a lab
at biotech near tulane university
can i use your flow core services
yes we collaborate with external people
investigators from different
universities and companies so if you're
interested in using it definitely get in
touch
fantastic thank you and the second
question is what types of cells
have your flow core sorted on the pitot
on our side we've sorted
a wide variety from
like granulomas from lungs infected with
tuberculosis
as well as mucosal samples
and pbmc
and
lymph node
so we can do all kinds of tissues
fantastic
do you have any
lab sorting samples from covid19
patients right now
yes we we do have labs supporting topic
19 patients um they'd be uh you know
they're treated just as any other
hazardous samples
and there is a publication if anybody's
interested
feel free to
comment in the chat and we can
get that to you after the webinar thanks
fantastic
the next question we have is um we would
like to sort
gfp positive bacteria is that possible
with this system
what decontamination procedures would i
need
so yes this that is positive possible
with
the title and when it comes to
decontamination uh it's really simple
all you need to do is dispose of the
cartridge so as as you saw in the
presentations uh everything the entire
sample is enclosed in the cartridge
there's no fluidics throughout the
actual instrument to contaminate it so
again throwing away that cartridge would
be the
cleaning and decan decontamination
process
fantastic well thank you so much matt
and marissa do you have any final
comments for our audience today
i would say thanks to everybody that is
attending um live today and in the
future recorded and thanks so much for
marissa and her team for all the the
hard work uh on this uh this project
awesome thank you guys again
for your time today and for your
important research
we would also like to thank lab roots
and our sponsor miltoni biotech for
underwriting today's educational webcast
before i go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
routes will alert you via email
when it's available for replay we
encourage you to share that email with
your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
until next time goodbye